now social distancing from reality
that's the focus of tonight's angle the
less rules have you noticed this they
never seem to apply to them now we've
seen this play out with governor Ralph
Northam not wearing his mask at the
beach or governor Whitmer's hubby
traveling to their family cabin up north
or governor Pritzker's family escaping
from Illinois to that awful dangerous
state of Florida Mayor Lori Lightfoot
she got her hairstyle that she kept
salons closed for everyone else in
Chicago but if you still want it to give
these blue state governors and mayor's
the benefit of the doubt on these kovat
lockdowns well know you can disabuse
yourself of that notion for good in late
april mayor de Blasio denounced Hasidic
Jews who gathered for a funeral in
Brooklyn and he used the police to break
it up the notion that people would
gather in large numbers and even they
mean to would spread a disease that will
kill other members of the community is
just unacceptable to me if you saw anger
and frustration you're right I spoke out
of real distress that people's lives
were in danger before my eyes and I was
not going to tolerate it so people's
lives were in danger at the funeral okay
but when throngs of looters roam the
streets to smash and grab and push aside
or worse anyone in their way suddenly
there's zero concern for Public Health
kovat and the police by de Blasio are
told to use a light touch overwhelmingly
peaceful protests
protesters respecting the ground rules
set by police police doing exactly what
they are so good at there's a small
anarchists Creek that's in violence and
then there's a small criminal element
that's been violent but you're talking
about a infinitesimally percentage
compared to the overwhelming majority
the protesters who have been people know
no code no common concerns so but if
thousands of people show up and let's
say let's move on to Charlotte north
Carolina to march against police
brutality okay they're welcome fine so
your right to peacefully protest but if
thousands of RNC attendees want a rally
in Charlotte two months from now
they're called irresponsible dangerous
selfish the president's extremely
irresponsible bullying and potentially
deadly threat today in the middle of
this deadly pandemic to move the
Republican National Convention from
Charlotte he wants what 20,000 people to
gather in the arena they're packed
screaming shouting on top of each other
right in the midst of this pandemic is
that what are you saying have any of you
seen the crowds in Raleigh and Charlotte
North Carolina well if you want to open
your restaurants doors to customers
they're gonna stop you or they're gonna
send state inspectors and they're gonna
have measuring tapes and they're gonna
make sure that your salad bar is in
order but if you want to ransack a
restaurant they'll give you the green
light and if you want to go to church
they'll send cops out to harass you but
if you want to burn down the church
they'll basically look the other way or
excuse it if you want to protest the
lockdowns at the State Capitol you're
called a terrorist and a threat to
public health and safety but now if
you're marching in a crowd carrying a
sign that says F Trump you're organizing
for change
no kovat problems there and if you're
thinking about let's say hitting the
beach this virus doesn't take the
weekends off this virus doesn't go home
because it's a beautiful sunny day
around our coasts but apparently the
virus has taken the entire week off or
it's just over all together and they
didn't bother telling us the bottom line
is that lock downs and rules were good
when they made your lives inconvenient
and took away things that were essential
to you but suddenly when the lockdown
though all the rules interfered with
achieving their political goals they no
longer mattered so much for phases one
two three and four
paging doctor foul Qi well this is all
political in the end for demo
gratz all of it they want to stop
President Trump and his supporters from
having rallies or even a convention
meanwhile they applaud tens of thousands
of people packed tightly into streets
and parks to support their own efforts
to defeat him isn't that a neat trick
well what about these these protests
peaceful protests we've said this night
after night it's the hallmark of any
free society and we applaud peaceful
protests as we explained for months two
left wingers who tried to force us to
stay home but the left their protests
have become essentially right now part
of a religion that is a sin so that must
be protected but it's also become part
social club and the same geniuses who
love to mock Baptists are out in the
streets with their own rituals
membership rules they have punishment
for heretics even and a scene that
looked like Jonestown meets Pilates a
bunch of rich white liberals gathered in
Bethesda Maryland suburb of Washington
DC to repeat their almost religious
mantras about racism anti blackness or
violence
I will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
and everything in my powers and to take
my community
I will love my black neighbors the same
as my white ones now let's be clear
everyone is infuriated anyone with a
shred of decency about what happened to
George Floyd
everyone wants justice to be done but
those creepy rallies have nothing to do
with George Floyd at least for most of
the people on the left his tragedy is
their excuse look the folks you see
yelling at cops on TV a lot of the
wealthy suburban kids I guess they're
tired of sitting home playing you know
video games they're buying stuff on
Amazon Prime they're trying to check
their privilege while checking their
Apple watches the left wants everyone on
their knees not in prayer for racial
healing or George Floyd but in
submission to their ever-growing list of
demands
today they demand we defund the police
you know most people don't realize that
only 5% of the arrests that happen in
the country actually happened for a
violent crime we don't need to fund
policing in the way that we do we have
to shrink the role of the policing
apparatus wholly well tomorrow they may
demand abolishing prisons altogether
except for the people they don't like
liberals used to celebrate the
individual I remember that they
encourage you to be your own true self
free expression was celebrated but now
it's really bizarre because they're all
about enforcing their own orthodoxy
their own conformity in speech and
belief you deviate from their ever
changing moving goalposts and they'll
excommunicate you at once they have no
interest in debate and who can blame
them they can't defend their lousy ideas
or their hatred of America and they have
no idea how to make anyone's life better
really better so that rather distract
you the latest 2-minute the symbol or
hate or maybe you know some acapella
singing on YouTube make everyone feel
good for the moment
it doesn't make anyone's life really
better certainly doesn't put more money
in your pocket today they're trying to
keep us trapped in a never-ending cycle
of meaningless sloganeering and protest
selfies
it's like eating junk food it tastes
good in the moment but it's not gonna
make you stronger if we had an honest
media they'd do more than just reacting
to president Trump's tweets or his walk
across the park to st. John church then
be asking tough questions like this Vice
President Biden if you're such a
champion of minorities why do you oppose
educational choice for disadvantaged
families in schools and if you knew mr.
Biden how to heal a racial divide why
didn't you and President Obama do it
over the eight years you were in the
White House why didn't you fight against
all those jobs being shipped overseas to
China why did it take president Trump to
pass criminal justice reform fortunately
the whole world hasn't yet become a
giant Student Center there are still
grown-up people with real money making
real bets on the future and those people
the investors who drive our markets they
see a very different world from that
scrawled on signs by English majors who
know more about Pokemon than the
founders of our country investors seem
to be optimistic about who will win this
battle of ideas even after a pandemic
and after days of unrest they're still
betting on America the Dow shot over
26,000 today it's stunning we're coming
back and that means more jobs for
Americans of all races and creeds and
who would want to protest against that
and that's the angle
now speaking of twisting the data the
left is doing just that to fuel the
narrative that police departments are
inherently systemic Lee racist so what
are the numbers actually tell us
according to a Washington Post database
that tracks these numbers police
officers fatally shot a thousand four
people one thousand four people in 2019
of those only 41 were unarmed
if you break those numbers down among
race you find twenty of the
unarmed were white while ten were black
as long as we're looking at those
numbers according to the FBI 89 police
officers 89 were killed in the line of
duty last year